the eh-2-zed of isms of vampirism what
is vampires the dictionary definition is
that it refers to the habits and
characteristics of vampires we might
think that that means rising from the
dead to prowl through the night while
wrapped in a voluminous black cloak
those possessing long a sharp canine
teeth with which to bite the necks of
victims and suck their blood but modern
vampires are less likely to be found in
graveyards than in books and films such
as a Twilight series or in Buffy the
Vampire Slayer when the term first
emerged though things were rather
different vampires were first discovered
in the early 18th century at the borders
of austria-hungary reports of witches
ghosts and various demons sucking human
blood go back to earliest times but it
was not until 1725 that vampires first
appeared in a report written by an Army
Medical Officer on the activities of
Serbian soldiers over the course of
eight days in that year in a village of
Kisel over nine people have been
strangled and then had their blood
sucked the man who believed responsible
have been dead and buried for 10 weeks
we had apparently risen from the grave
to do so the soldiers dug up his corpse
soon found it to be quite fresh with
blood in its mouth they drove a stake
through his heart and cremated the body
it was the first reported case of
vampirism a newspaper in Vienna carried
the report and the phenomenon has spread
within a few years vampirism seem to be
rife in Eastern Europe the emperor sent
teams of military surgeons to
investigate him before more topsis they
found that the cases were remarkably
consistent dozens of articles and books
were published on the subject by medical
researchers and vampires became a hot
topic of debate in the Enlightenment
vampirism was a recognized condition
attested by large numbers of witnesses
and had characteristic signs and
symptoms such as corpses having fresh
blood running through their veins some
researchers but the appearance is down
to mass trauma and delusion some to diet
or accidental drug use causing
hallucinations some to unusual chemicals
in the earth affecting decomposition
some to highly contagious diseases
others however argued at the phenomenon
was rampant and needed to be dealt with
by the authorities theologians joined
the fray arguing that vampires were
physical beings approved the existence
of an afterlife philosophers meanwhile
were concerned as a widespread evidence
supporting the existence of vampires
cast a whole valley of testimony and
eyewitness verification into doubt
having begun among Serbian villagers
vampires have now spread through
European society as a way to describe
politicians landlords businessman and
even theater critics It was as if
vampires were moving up the social scale
it was not until a century had passed
that the aspiring writer dr. John and
Paula Dory wrote the first vampire tale
in English he made the vampire an
aristocrat and paved the way for Bram
Stoker's classic novel Dracula published
78 years later it is to Polidori and
Stoker and dozens of Victorian vampire
tales that we owe the found and stylish
creature familiar to us today but
remember that vampirism was first
investigated by doctors government
officials and philosophers it therefore
has much to teach us about what it is
and is not to be human about how far we
are simply flesh and bone not about
exploitation and bleeding others dry and
how we should treat those who despite
appearances may be not like us at all
[Music]